there's still other things you can do I
do think guys should maximize
um
their social skills fish in their hole I
think guys should learn Charisma I think
guys should maximize their looks
especially in the face and I think that
guy should go to the gym when you say
maximize their looks in the face how
would that how would that work working
out frequently not in their face oh in
their face yeah you know get a little
shape up you know get the beard so many
people can make a hug get a nice get a
nice haircut yeah I've seen some sorcery
yeah and they come out when they come
out a woman a woman has to sleep with
these guys at the end of the day just to
like what she sees a bit Yeah in the in
the pickup Artistry sort of uh
communities number one uh thing is the
number one thing who puts women off is
is badly groomed yeah I've worked I've
worked I've worked I used to coach a
little bit of that to be honest and and
what being work rooms smelling good
we're we're in nice clothes not
expensive just things that's a tailored
to you shower yeah have style that
attracts the sorts of women that you
like I swear there's a Kevin Samuels
video of He's teaching men how to use
especially I'm curious you said you've
done dating coaching yeah you I still do
a bit you do it yeah I've just studied
it and oh you don't actually I haven't I
haven't okay I just I don't know how
many clients have you had enough that
you could get a general picture yeah
okay because like the one thing I'm
curious
um a lot of the guys that do it are they
from single mother homes because I'm
thinking like it's just a hypothesis I'm
wondering if maybe they're not like
groomed okay no no
no that's a good question but no it's
actually really random okay it's really
around I could actually
I'll be better off breaking it down by
race but I'm not gonna do that here but
I'll be better off breaking my race
actually
I want to say hello yeah you can you can
like Asian guys go for it a lot do you
feel that they should guys go through
what is it they go for they they come to
me a lot Asian guys yeah they're the
leaders all right because because
there's an American audience here when
we say Asian okay I'm talking about
um
um and then you get uh I'd say European
like Caucasian and I'd say Black's kind
of the smallest yeah do you feel even
though I think a lot of them there's a
lot of um I think a lot of black men
walk around with a lot of ego and they
wouldn't really want to come yeah
foreign
my friends that are from afro-caribbean
sort of backgrounds and and
they just have game no no
we don't always let me let me let me let
me say something about that a lot of
them don't have games yeah but what it
is is that I've been a black man in in
the UK all of my life and I know that I
can when I used to go out to the club so
don't go out to the clubs anymore
but when I I could walk into a club with
mostly European women
and just get attention
I don't have game
but there's something in their heads
that when they see me objectives
when they're like oh oh that guy right
so it's not necessarily game like I I
think a lot of black men are just
desired by other people other races
that's that's what I personally growing
up all of my life I'm 41 years old
that's me growing up in the UK saying
okay cool like I've been to all types of
situations
and women that women that aren't because
you can go to if we talk about there's a
guy that was actually in Thailand as a
matter of fact
um who's getting a lot of black men to
go to Thailand and there's a guy that
was walking around Thailand as a black
man and seeing the attention that he
gets listen
I'm not saying it's a good thing bad
thing I'm just saying in certain
scenarios and you know as a black man
they just desire you know do you think
it's because
um like you know like if you're not
allowed to have something you then want
to be a taboo so like it's like they're
maybe culturally their families may be
like no you could be and so it's more
desirable because it's like yeah
it's for sexual pleasure it's not
necessarily for a long term you do have
to be a certain type of black girl as
well I like no Steve Urkel's getting all
that action
a nerdy like a nerdy even
evens to be honest like they don't
really get any play this is this is the
strangest thing because a lot of the
guys I know uh afro-caribbeans are I.T
guys the programmers hardcore like.net
ASP and they still get they still get
action but they've got game they they
walk into a game maybe the ones you know
and you can talk to everyone and anyone
that if I point those friends of mine I
was I mean when I was young I was scared
to death of talking to women women were
like alien creatures and a friend of
mine who was from Ghana I point to any
woman he would straight up walk up to
her and start talking to her as a woman
that rejected three or four other guys
before before him and I said okay that
one he went up to her he was sitting
down talking to her for 50 minutes
I'm like how what did you even say yes
I see so many guys complain about women
but I know they haven't maximize their
social skills maybe a cultural thing
because in other cultures
whether they be
um South Asian whether they be African
socialization is part of the culture our
culture do you know what I mean like
learning just how to speak to Auntie
so-and-so or even like it's just part of
our 100 culture that maybe that and also
you know
um being a black person trying to you
know get jobs and stuff you kind of have
to be funny you kind of have to like
make people think you're less threatened
yeah so you have to learn all these
skills yeah you learn all these skills
along the way that make you just happen
to be great with women sometimes you
know and and so that's what it is it's
not necessarily a game it's just
interesting social skills
um I'm gonna ask another question
uh on topic do you think the reason for
the men or sorry do you think the reason
for women over here being less desirable
is
the f word
the what the f word feminism Oh I
thought you I was like what's saying it
there's a reason why men are finding
women over in the west so this is I
think it's alienate man it's feminism
yeah I think it alienates 100 I think it
gives um
I think it gives women a false kind of
um
sense of entitlement and I think that it
makes them feel like victims even though
they probably weren't even alive
when when uh times were a lot more
exactly I said they don't even read what
already happened and I think that um it
makes them feel like the victim so it
gives them the right to act a certain
way and treat men a certain way and it's
it's quite sad really because I think we
both lose it's because we're at feminism
allowed women to be bailed out of every
single bad decision that we make ever
like if you want to if we want to sleep
around there's birth control yeah if
that doesn't work we have abortion if
that doesn't work you can get government
assistance for being a single mother
um if that doesn't work
um you can you know marry someone it
does could be the father of your kid as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible